you're not a real friend with this
person well you're attracted yeah that's
you're attracted I don't want to [ __ ] my
friends
you're not my friend but
Ryan's my friend right do I have a
secret idea of like the [ __ ] ride
that's so true I would hope that I would
you can't be comfortable alone that's
not a friendship no yeah because when I
hang out with you Ryan I'm not imagining
you wrapping your mouth around my dick
you can't have enough authentic
friendship when it's not real when
you're thinking about railing Ryan in
the back I think regardless it's not
that easy by the way what kind of friend
are you anyway then you wouldn't throw
something to your voice all I'm saying
it's like if you're attracted to that
person I don't think it can be super
platonic you're gonna make it you're
saying you wouldn't [ __ ] [ __ ] you all
right oh [ __ ] you because he's an alpha
that's what I'm saying the duty of an
alpha male is also to be able to control
your desires because when I'm hanging
out with Ryan and I'm thinking about
sticking his ankles behind his back I'm
not gonna be his ears yeah yeah but I
look like I'm just spreading my cheeks
all day in front of you guys you have a
[ __ ] Vibe I seem ready Luke dude
look at his face right now the new Ryan